so I apologize um further from the con
I don't usually sound like this by the
bad cold okay and with all due respect
to diana and paul i do want to make a
case for an alternative to MOOCs and so
what I'm going to be talking about right
now isn't something that is in existence
but rather something that has yet to be
developed something that would require
input from all of us I want to make this
proposal in part because MOOCs has
dominated our thinking about online
education with some MOOC platforms such
as Kucera selling the terms of the
debate at the same time there's also
been a significant amount of criticism
pretty much cover well covered by the
media so I've included three articles
from The Chronicle of Higher Education
first about faculty at San Jose State
refusing to use the MOOC offered by
michael sandel 71 about mutual damir a
Princeton sociologist who has taught in
book 2 4000 students leaving kisara over
the licensing of his material and
finally about most recently about stems
and also trying to develop a competing
platform since Young's contract even
though it's a non-exclusive contract its
contract is with Kucera this is what
I'll be concentrating on and I should be
upfront about my misgivings as Lucas
mentions they have to do not only with
what I've been reading but also with the
fact that i have a website a course
website an experiment in online
education that cannot be fitted into the
Kosair format I'll get to that in a
minute but for now just let me talk
about three pedagogy concerns that often
come up regarding Kucera first and I
think this is what people worry about
the most it is for profit
it does have a financial obligation
towards its investors and it does seem
committed to a vision of higher
education that will allow state state
legislators to cut costs and perhaps
also cut funding for public at
universities certainly because kansara
is a MOOC platform education done on a
massive scale its courses do come in a
convenient package format finally and
this follows from the previous point
because this is distance learning it
tends to be at the expense of unsightly
kulti and face-to-face local
interactions in light of all this I'd
like to propose an alternative to Kucera
and two mooks in general we can call it
any number of things but for now I'm
just going to call it by its generic
name open source platform as its name
indicates it's not for profit it has no
prepackaged format instead in it's just
a digital environment that can be used
by multiple audiences at different
educational levels working at their own
pace and removed from the material as
they see fit under the creative commons
be why and see as a license is
commitment is to local input
collaboration improvisation so what
exactly is this um OOP sorry I forgot to
show you that this nice I'm this be why
ncsa license the three acronyms pretty
much sum up the conditions for use be
why I it requires proper attribution any
use of the material will have to carry
their knowledge Minh that it is by
so-and-so secondly MC non-commercial it
would not allowed material to use by any
sub profit entity and
SI share alike any work resulting from
the use of the material we have to be
distributed under similar non-commercial
license to give you a sense of what a
cost based on this open yeah this is
good mmm give yourself some one of
course develop on Creative Commons I
look like a large home to my own course
American literature in the world it is
currently a senior seminar inspiring
next year is actually going to be a
freshman Simon biggest materials pray
father non-technical and even there's an
undergraduate course it has opened up a
number of possibilities graduate
teaching currently it supports a
graduate conference sponsored by the
Carnegie Library the Graduate School and
ten academic departments last year the
twelve percent of the conference came
from all over the country from public
and private universities from the East
Coast Midwest west coast in addition um
let me show you the the conference last
year
can't seem to get to well you go and
look it up I can't seem to get to the
participants in addition in addition to
this conference the website also has a
blog a Facebook page Twitter Facebook
page so it's the facebook page and I
wanted yoke Matthew this
I'll feel close to this oh well um I
just want to look a little bit of this
and then go back okay so it has it has
um there's conference a block a Facebook
page wiki articles written primarily by
undergraduates okay so this is this is
the person who's most responsible for
running the wiki articles I'm he's not
an English major he's an economics major
and for the past two years he's worked
as an intern at mckinsey & company so
this is a very unusual writer of wiki
allah codes but I take pride in the fact
that it's not just English Alicia people
who'll be contributing to this and it
has has caused material I'm just just
going to show you the to supervise the
survive for more information in the
world among a course that it's going to
be taught in this way illusion film
course called a private eye drop by Paul
grinstead and I'll intractable and we've
also put that syllabus on the website as
well so this is something that we're
working on not making sure that if they
want to other faculty can also put the
course material on the American
literature in the world website in my
spirit will also be developing three
longer-term projects all which will
require collaboration the first is the
media lab in some in collaboration with
teen Robin law juicer and trip to
graduate school and show patrick i TS to
showcase national humanities projects by
faculty and students secondly we are
also putting together a print anthology
that's edited by myself to graduate
students and an undergraduate
and then we also have public humanities
component and it's in development as you
can see but we hope to have a new heaven
food festival because a lot of material
in American lunch on the worst do food
so with I will be good to have a film
festival finishing food trucks and then
something that's going to take a little
more work an alternative to
incarceration program which with involve
juvenile delinquents meaning attacks
together and then writing a song
producing artwork or putting on a play
based on that tax and in exchange for
reduced prison sentences and will record
an archive and digitize an archive all
that so as evidenced by American
literature in the world to open as
evidenced by American version the world
open source platform has a number of
benefits not available from a MOOC
platform it is usable by multiple
audiences it provides the location for
undergraduates graduate students other
faculty libraries art galleries as well
as I TS to work together and finally is
outreach to the rest of the world it's
matched by its outreach to the local
community plus the open source platform
doesn't have the marketing power that
Kucera does but it can build up a modest
and sustainable audience over the years
it can be accessed through multiple
platforms through its own course website
and Facebook page through YouTube in
itunes and help awesome to a central
portal that will feature of the
different components
yells online education including open
Yale courses Coursera courses and then
this open source platform which should
put you in a cage unique position in the
debate on books